american express halftime report
raptors uh match their season high in
points for a half
with 77. oh that's terence davis for one
of his two
77-68 raptors trying to sweep the nets
they uh
they are going to have to do that
without kyle lowry the rest of the way
you saw the video of him
leaving the arena after uh spraining his
ankle
uh chuck's here kenny's here shaq is
here
and here is the best game of the
playoffs so far no
this is just a small version of it right
now
but the clippers in dallas play in
overtime
kawhi leona was amazing today doncic was
amazing
williams was amazing trey burke was
amazing a lot of guys were great
um i didn't like this that dallas
clipped his last possession oh this is
uh
marcus morris and so the clippers got
the lead 133-132
oh switch don't switch don't swim here
tom luca
oh and that is your old ball game
game winner from doncic
no you got to switch everything they say
in these in these instances but i would
have loved it
why that's every basketball player's
dream kidney that caps a 43 point
17 rebound 13 assist
triple double and it ties the series at
two games a piece
and the and the mavs did that without
kristaps porzingis it was a late scratch
with a sore right knee but the series is
tied after that 135 133 win how'd you
like to hear from luca
yeah good here we go i was just trying
to make it you know
i can't explain the emotions i had you
know
when not only would he go when the ball
goes in
when i see the whole team like running
towards me that was something special
one of the best feelings i ever had as a
player
and it's just something special man this
team is something special
the way he computes the game um
and you know he sees the game in you
know
6g it's not 5g it's 6g it's it's another
level beyond what
most people see it so um
you know just a just a very very special
player and this this game today was uh
you know was from another planet
at t gonna get on that 6g
this is the best thing about sports
right here uh
team ever did that to you guys
i
every basketball player has a
growing up in the backyard in the
projects of leeds alabama
kenny in uh new york shaq i don't know
where he was born
every player always wants to have a ball
in the air i wasn't born that was found
on the train truck
i mean think about it katy isn't that
the greatest friend of the ball anytime
you're in the yard you're like this is a
tough shot
you know why this isn't even a tougher
shot because the game isn't tied i think
when the game is tied that's an easier
winning game-winning shot when you're
down and you have to take it
hey do you want to you want us to save
this for you right here chuckster uh
only three players the 40 15 and 10
club in a playoff game uh underdog hey
jack you an oscar and luca hello
siri anytime you're on the list with
oscar robinson
at the great octa office is a good thing
wow i mean this was this was something
and
look shaq dallas no porzingis you're
down
21 and you come back and win that game
to tie the series man
listen luke don't get me wrong luca
dunches
is a great player i'm not saying he's
not a great player the little argument
me and chuck had i'm just saying that
show the same enthusiasm for others who
have done the same
i played 19 years watched the game 20
years before that i've seen this before
yes he is a great player he's done a
great thing a lot of people were talking
smack calling names and he wanted to
show that he can play
he's always had the advantage because if
you know anything about european
basketball and the fans
they're not soft over there so he played
in the league over there four or five
years ago with grown men over there when
he's a teenager
and you know and arena's over there
ernie they start fires and they have
fights so i know
yeah that's not what impressed me today
today
was you know we always talk about we're
not going to lose today
he willed that team when they were down
20
with no prezingers they could have
packed it in uh like my likes last week
you ain't show the same enthusiasm
that's all i'm saying oh wait i picked
the trail blazers no but you wasn't
going oh there we go
you wasn't doing all that stuff that's
all i'm talking about ernie
when you can wield your team i mean when
you're down
20 no prezingers my man's his ankle's
probably still sore from the last game
and he's like nah we're not going to
pack it in this is what i said earlier
about this is why they were clear and
present danger
to the uh just like the lake we were
talking about portland now and in the
beginning of the season that's
being at its bubble i said this is not
luca dante from 2020. he had three and a
half months off
it's like an off season we're not seeing
all-star luca we're going to see
mvp lucas so i said i wouldn't want to
play against the dallas mavericks and
porzingis being
possibly healthy because we're seeing
the next year of them
not the current year of them that's why
bevan booker looked the way he did
that's why dame dollars looking the way
is
and that's why luca is doing his thing
135 133 2-2 series matt beverly coming
back the next game
what patrick pepper going to do for that
dude nothing that would come back pat
double gonna get killed if he tried to
go out there
[Music]
you're watching the